[Music]
the Triforce has been at the center of
the Legend of Zelda ever since the very
first title on the NES quite literally
as without it the fantasy world we all
know and love wouldn't be able to exist
it's the governing Force the master
force that binds and governs everything
and everyone the goddess has created
during the formation of the universe
we've witnessed firsthand what happens
when the power of gold ceases to be in A
Link Between Worlds the kingdom of loru
who got rid of their Triforce fell into
Decay its very Foundation crumbled the
skies darkened and slowly but surely the
land tore itself apart it was a reminder
that despite being a main source of
conflict the Triforce cannot simply be
taken out of the equation and it's
actually one-off if not the greatest
mystery of the Zelda Universe no one
knows for sure why the gods left the
Triforce behind in the first place or
why it exists all we know is that it
must in Skyward Sword Zelda theorizes
that it was the Creator's way of giving
hope to Mortals a way to seize their own
destiny and shape the world they live in
as they see fit free from Divine
dictatorship so to speak it's a great
Theory it explains the reality bending
properties of the Triforce and its
ability to literally alter space and
time itself The Relic was purposely
designed so it cannot be used by gods I
guess to even out the playing field it
doesn't judge it doesn't distinguish
between good and evil it just is and
whoever manages to get a hold of it has
the power to decide the fate of the
world around them as such it was quite
unusual that the Triforce was seemingly
absent from breath of the wild not once
is it mentioned by name nor is it part
of the main goal or story which is
definitely not the first time by any
means but in the case of these stories
its absence has a clear explanation
either the game doesn't take place in
Hyrule and is more of a Side Story or it
takes place in an era where knowledge
about the sacred Relic and its location
has been all but lost the events of
diminished cap and four Swords For
example took place during a time when
the Triforce was successfully being kept
Hidden Away by the Light sage raru and
wouldn't be rediscovered and obtained
until the events of Ocarina of Time at
the end of the Wind Waker the kingdom of
Hyrule along with its Legacy disappeared
beneath the great sea and so subsequent
Adventures focused on new lands and new
conflicts while the Old Kingdom and the
legend of the Triforce remained buried
and forgotten however the exclusion of
the Triforce in breath of the wild
cannot be explained in the same way at
least not right now mainly because it is
yet to receive an official timeline
placement so we don't know in which
state or location the Triforce was last
in prior to it the one thing we do know
about the game's position in the
chronology is that it takes place
inconceivably long after all the other
events in the series so long in fact
that the original timeline as a whole
has faded into a distant myth as such
the most likely scenario is that similar
to the aforementioned titles the
existence and whereabouts of the
Triforce has simply been lost a time
again hidden away and forgotten by most
that being said we do still see
depictions of the Triforce in this era
in various forms an architecture
ceremonial outfits weapons and armor
even the ruins of ancient long-lost
civilizations like the zonai displayed
the three virtues of power wisdom and
courage that make up the Triforce in the
case of the zonai we currently don't
know what their understanding of and
relationship to the Triforce was but for
the other existing cultures in this day
and age the portrayal of the Sacred
triangle seems to be nothing more than a
leftover tradition an archaic symbol of
the ancient world whose true meaning and
Origins are no longer understood as
stated before the Triforce is never
mentioned by name nor by one of its many
pseudonyms not by the king not Zelda not
even the wise and enigmatic chica monks
from 10 000 years ago which is quite
ironic because breath of the wild is the
one game where the attributes of the
Triforce would have benefited the
kingdom immensely it has the power to
undo all the damage all the loss of life
caused by the Calamity you would think
it would be the first thing they would
turn to as a possible solution the fact
that it's never even brought up speaks
volumes about how much of a distant
memory the Triforce has become of course
tears of the Kingdom May reintroduce it
in some way maybe through Ganondorf or
some other ancient being who possesses
knowledge of the ancient past but until
then it seems the sacred triangles and
its whereabouts will remain a mystery
foreign
force was present in breath of the wild
but in a new context there's been a lot
of discussion and theories about this
imagery the symbol that appears on the
back of Zelda's hand on multiple
occasions as well as inside the massive
ball of energy she conjured up and
sealed Ganon with during the final
battle it's the closest thing we saw to
the actual Triforce and its appearance
has led many to wonder what it could
mean some suggest that it's nothing more
than a rune or an Arcane symbol the
likes of which you would see manifest
when casting a powerful spell or
incantation so it's simply a visual
representation of Zelda's ceiling power
which is obviously tied to the power of
the Gods in some way which kinda makes
sense after all it's not uncommon for a
Triforce shape to appear when Certain
Magical events take place but there's
also those who speculate that this might
actually be the real Triforce and that
Zelda is somehow tapping into its power
to do what previously could only be
achieved by multiple people combining
forces to seal away the ever so
persistent Demon King but how is that
possible as far as we know Zelda never
obtained the Triforce the way it would
be done in the traditional way not to
mention it goes against what we know
about the Triforce and its inner
workings the only way Zelda could be in
possession of the complete Triforce
without actually finding and collecting
it first is if it was somehow passed
down to her unknowingly we've seen
pieces of it being passed down like how
Twilight Princess Link inherited the
Triforce of Courage from the hero of
time but never the whole thing is it
even possible to not only carry the full
Triforce inside oneself for an extended
period of time but also pass it on
through a bloodline well today I want to
try to build a case that yes what we see
here could very well be the real thing
and the evidence requires that we go
back to one of the earliest points in
the Zelda chronology to a story which I
feel may have been vastly misinterpreted
over the years so sit back grab some
triangle-shaped snacks and let's dive
into it
thank you
before we get into the possible evidence
for Zelda's possession of the complete
Triforce let's first expound upon the
inner workings of it and establish what
it can and cannot do based on experience
from past games as stated before the
Triforce makes no distinction between
good or evil it can grant any wish to
those who've earned it regardless of
their goal or motivation however
wielding or controlling the omnipotent
power does come with certain rules and
limitations one of which we already
touched upon it cannot be used by gods
when it comes to Mortal beings as far as
we know there's only two ways to do it
those who possess a strong balance
between the virtues of power wisdom and
courage may use its power immediately
upon acquisition if said balance is not
present The Relic splits and Only The
Virtue that reflects their heart the
most will remain with them while the
other pieces are bestowed upon chosen
individuals alive in that era who
reflect the remaining two virtues in
this scenario should the original
founder still wish to acquire and wield
the complete Relic they would have to
extract the other two pieces from those
who carry them they don't necessarily
certainly have to kill them but usually
it doesn't happen voluntarily The Only
Exception we've seen so far is when
Zelda allegedly passes her life force
and with it the Triforce of wisdom onto
midna to save her life we've also seen
cases where an outsider who's not part
of the Trinity is able to steal pieces
of The Relic from the original Three for
example Yuga merged with a revived Gan
and granting him the Triforce of power
meanwhile princess Hilda stole the
Triforce of wisdom from Zelda
subsequently Yuga Ganon then sees his
Hilda's piece and if it wasn't for link
putting up a good fight he would have
gotten his too close but no cigar one of
the triforce's many interesting
properties is that it's metaphysical it
can exist as both an object but also as
pure energy or Force as it's called
force is referred to as the breath of
life itself and every living creature
possesses a fraction of it some more
than others individuals who possess an
unusually high amount of force include
the sages members of the shika tribe
like impa and Mas koshia link himself
and most of all Zelda which is why she
is often been the target of antagonists
who attempt to extract her life force
through ritual to achieve certain goals
force can also be stored inside objects
the master sword and force sword being
Prime examples of items infused with an
incredible amount of force which grants
them their demon slaying ability and the
Triforce sits at the top of it all as
the object with the highest
concentration of force known to man as
mentioned before its physical version
can split apart into the three virtues
and each of these can be shattered into
even more pieces we've seen them split
into many small fragments or in two
halves with one part being carried
around like a necklace reassembled
basically the fragments can always be
reunited and breaking it up doesn't seem
to damage it in any way it's just that
the smaller the piece the less power
you'll gain from it when a piece of the
Triforce houses itself inside of a
living being it loses its physical
properties and merges with their life
force we can see this happening most
clearly in the Wind Waker one moment
link has the object in front of him the
next it's gone and suddenly the mark of
the Triforce appears on the back of his
hand that said the physical
manifestation of The Relic seems to be
its natural state it's described that
when those who carry parts of the
Triforce inside their bodies draw close
to each other the pieces will start to
resonate longing to become one again and
when they do it reverts back to its
physical form shortly after once again
we witnessed this most clearly in the
Wind Waker Ganondorf successfully
extracts all the pieces including his
own after which the physical Triforce
emerges in A Link to the Past Ganon was
also in possession of the complete
object and here too it's not stored
inside of his body but rather he keeps
it hidden away in the back room of his
Tower in A Link Between Worlds it's a
little less clear what happens exactly
link defeats Yuga Ganon and then next
thing we know the Triforce is back in
the sacred realm so either return here
on its own or maybe link brought it in
here with him we don't know for sure we
don't actually see him extracting power
and wisdom from Yuga like we saw him do
to heal that moment before there's no
full Triforce symbol present on this
person so I'm inclined to believe that
it returned to this sacred Realm by
itself but even if link did carry the
complete Triforce inside the fact
remains that first of all it was very
brief and second when he and Zelda
actually used its power it was outside
his body again I could see that perhaps
someone could potentially carry all
three pieces if only for a brief moment
but when the time comes to actually
wielded experience dictates that it
always reverts back to the physical
Triforce never before have we seen
someone use its power while it's still
bound to their life force not by Ganon
not link nor Princess Zelda it's been
speculated that the reason why it
manifests as a physical object once it's
reunited is because it would be too much
force for one individual to handle which
would explain why Ganon hides it away as
opposed to keeping it honest person
because you know that would be the
safest place to store it I would say as
such it's hard to believe that someone
can not only carry the full extent of
the almighty power inside them for their
entire life but also pass it on to their
children and their children's children
and so on if that was possible you'd
think that someone would have done it by
now that is unless we can find an
example of someone who did someone who
likes Zelda from breath of the wild
could have been carrying the complete
Triforce inside for their whole life
perhaps unknowingly
[Music]
I'm sure many of you had already guessed
where this was leading to I mean I did
say one of the earliest points in the
Zelda chronology and there's only one
game that fits that description The
Legend of Zelda Skyward pumpkin when it
comes to an attempt to explain what we
saw in breath of the wild this is as
good a place as any to look for answers
after all this is the story where the
concept of the Goddess hylia a
reincarnation as a mortal and the
creation of Zelda's long lineage were
all established in regards to the
Triforce the strategy was that since
gods are unable to use it hylia would
give up on her Divinity reincarnate into
a mortal body that being the first Zelda
and wield the Triforce that way to
eradicate demise once and for all
however the plan changed when the mice
started breaking free from his seal
earlier than the goddess had anticipated
since she was the only one powerful
enough to uphold the sea on demise the
task of finding and using the Triforce
became Link's responsibility instead
with his previous task of forging the
master sword completed he set out to
find an ancient song uncovers the secret
entrance to Sky keep which was hidden
inside skyloft all along collects the
three pieces of the Triforce and uses it
to wish for demises well demise and
these are the events pertaining to the
Triforce and its role in the story of
Skyward Sword or so we were led to
believe there's aspects to this part of
the story that never made a whole lot of
sense to me and I think there's a very
good chance that we may have
collectively misinterpreted or
misunderstood some of what the writers
were trying to convey you may have
noticed that while traversing the rooms
and Halls of Sky keep that the Triforce
pieces are not obtained in the usual way
like we saw in many of the other games
in all three rooms that house a piece of
The Relic there's an additional step you
need to do before you actually collect
it link will trust his sword into a
Crest on the floor his spirit will then
leave his body and materializes inside a
disconnected room where the Triforce
Pace rests on a pedestal the room has no
entrance or exits the only way out is to
pick up the Triforce and Link will
return to his physical body which is
still standing there in its original
pose kneeling down clutching the hilt of
the master sword of course if you've
gotten this far into the game this
segment isn't anything new because we
already did something similar four times
before skykeep the sacred trials known
as the Silent Realm
so what is the Silent Realm well we'll
get into that in a moment but for now I
can tell you what the Silent Realm
definitely isn't and in my opinion this
is where the first major misconception
about Skyward sword's story lies some
have proposed that since the Triforce is
ultimately found on this ethereal plane
it could be that this place is the
sacred realm after all when the Triforce
is not in the possession of one or more
individuals the sacred realm is where
it's usually located I'm not going to go
too deep into the sacred realm itself
because that is a subject I will be
covering in depth in a follow-up video
to this one but I can see why people
have made the connection between the two
Realms since there are definitely
similarities accessing both has involved
link driving the master sword into the
ground or into a pedestal in some way at
least in Ocarina of Time that is in the
same instance link so is trapped inside
the sacred realm for seven years and in
Skyward Sword link 2 travels to this
Mysterious World in spirit only but for
all its similarities the theories that a
connection also ignore some of the huge
differences between the two first of all
the sacred realm is not a spirit world
and has never been described as such
it's a real tangible place that is
connected to Hyrule just because the
hero of time was essentially put on ice
here until he was ready to go back
doesn't mean that everyone who visits
here can only do so in spirit form I
mean according to the stories battles
have taken place here Ganondorf his
minions and The Interlopers have all
been here in search of the Triforce heck
we see Lincoln Zelda visiting the place
in human form they don't glow they're
not translucent or hovering there's no
flames or particles emanating from them
like you would see spirits do nothing
that indicates that it's a spirit world
of any kind furthermore the Silent Realm
is described as a place that is only
accessible to highly as chosen hero not
even Phi who was created directly by the
goddess is allowed to follow him here
whereas Navi was able to join link into
the sacred realm just fine same goes for
the master sword itself which the hero
cannot carry with him inside the Silent
Realm while in the sacred realm he can
the second misconception about the
Silent Realm is that it's some sort of
purgatory or afterlife a dimension where
the spirits of the deceased go after
they pass on this too while an
understandable conclusion does not seem
to add up Phi never states that the
Silent Realm is a ghost Dimension
instead she calls it the domains of the
spirit not of spirits the spirit
singular and that link has been
temporarily separated from his physical
body to undergo a personal trial or
challenge that calls out to his mind
alone and again one has to ask if this
was some sort of General Spirit
Dimension how come Phi is not allowed
inside after all she is a spirit herself
so if it's not the sacred realm or
Purgatory what is it then those who've
extensively studied this island realm
and its Inspirations from real life
mythology like rinkuto for example have
come to a similar conclusion as I have
the Silent Realm is not a real place
well it is and it isn't depending on how
you look at it it's a visual
representation of Link's own Spirit or
our psyche made manifest by the power of
the Goddess his own personal mind space
which is why no one but him is able to
travel here I'm sure most of you are
familiar with the term soul searching
and well that's pretty much exactly what
link is doing here Link's task of
forging the master sword is an important
part of Skyward sword's narrative but
it's not the only thing he's doing he's
also forging the unbreakable Spirit of
the hero the same one that will be
passed on to Future heroes in times of
hardship in order to achieve this the
hero of the sky had to undergo spiritual
growth to cleanse himself of his own
impurities which according to Japanese
culture every individual has this
process of spiritual cleansing is often
compared to the life cycle of a lotus
flower which are born inside of a muddy
dirty pool then struggles to rise above
it until finally reaching the sunlight
and blooming into a beautiful flower the
Guardians are physical manifestations of
the hero's own mental obstacles his
fears his doubts his anger anything that
prevents him from achieving spiritual
Enlightenment when he allows these
obstructions to get to him his spirit
will shatter and he has to start over
like someone who allows themselves to be
snapped out of a deep meditation because
of distractions from the outside or from
within one's own mind this is the
Brilliance of some of Skyward Sword
storytelling whereas some may view the
silent realms purely from a gameplay
perspective nothing more than padding or
busy work those who look deeper into the
lore and symbolism will find that these
segments have been put in here by the
writers for a reason to tell a story and
it's not just a Mindless collect-a-thon
nope no no no
ah
so after that heartfelt speech let's
take a step back and address the
elephant in the room if the silent
realms represent Link's own psyche or
Spirit how come we also find the
Triforce here because that would suggest
that link had the complete Triforce
inside of him all this time and yeah
that is exactly what I'm proposing when
you really sit down and think about it
this whole ordeal of having to travel to
the Silent Realm to pick up the Triforce
is just extra busy work both on the side
of the developers who had to program all
of this as well as the player it would
have been so much easier to Simply have
a chest there which you need to open and
there you go but by adding that one
extra step I feel like Nintendo was
trying to tell us something it's
repeated throughout the game by multiple
NPCs that the Triforce is hidden
somewhere in skyloft but that nobody
knows where exactly and if it's still
there now not Phi not levius or the
dragons or any of the other higher
beings who serve hylia the only one who
allegedly knows the details is the
goddess herself and she doesn't exactly
spell it out for us even after
instructing link to go get the Triforce
she completely leaves out the part that
there's a huge building hidden inside
his own Hometown and that this is where
he'll find what he's looking for so
either she's being needlessly cryptic or
she doesn't want to risk demise or gear
him finding out the truth I think the
signs of Link possessing the complete
Triforce were there from the very
beginning the crest of the Triforce has
seen manifesting on the back of Link's
hand on three separate occasions it
starts with courage only then wisdom is
added and finally power marking the
first time ever in Zelda history that
someone possesses a crest of the
complete Triforce as opposed to only
parts of it and this all happened before
link ever collects the Triforce pieces
from Sky keep it should be noted that
historically having the Triforce Crest
on one's person has always meant that
they are in actual possession of it it
was never meant to symbolize having the
mere potential to wield it if that were
true loads of people would be walking
around with crests on the back of their
hand because surely link isn't the only
one out there who possesses great
courage or Zelda the only one with
profound wisdom no the crest means that
you have the Triforce okay some point
when Hilda steals Zelda's wisdom piece
her Crest disappears when Ganondorf died
at the end of Twilight Princess he lost
the Triforce of power and in the Wind
Waker the crest of Courage doesn't
become visible on Link's hand until he
obtains the physical piece first I could
go on but I think you get the point want
even more evidence here's a fun one
remember those pools of multi-colored
liquid inside the silent realms the game
calls it waking water and touching it
will immediately alert the Guardians to
your position regardless of how much is
left on the timer it's yet another
obstacle link has to avoid during his
collect-a-thon if you stop at one of
these pools and stare straight into it
this shape will appear do you see it
that is the Triforce not only that it's
the Triforce but mirrored see how
courage and wisdom are on the wrong side
it's a reflection what's interesting is
that this trick doesn't work if you just
Pan the camera above it or from other
angles it only appears when you switch
the first person mode and look at it
through Link's Eyes by the end it's firm
that yes the Triforce was indeed in
skyloft but I don't think it was in Sky
keep it never was it was hidden in a
place where no one would ever think to
look for it inside of an individual or
maybe even a bloodline I'm leaving that
part up in the air because once again
Link's parents are never mentioned or
even acknowledged not even by his
closest friends no explanation
whatsoever as to why is an orphan at the
age of 17 so for all we know he's a
force baby or something like Anakin
Skywalker either way hylia's plan worked
like a charm it flew under everybody's
radar including the villains of the
story in fact girihim brushes link off
as nothing more than an annoyance
someone who's way over their head and
doesn't play a part in this story it's
all about the goddess after all she's
the one who matters and by the time the
antagonist realized who link was and the
danger he poses it was already too late
with all that said if link had the
complete Triforce from the very
beginning how was he not aware of it and
why doesn't he just use it earlier in
the story we've seen other incarnations
of the hero use it without all this
Spiritual Awakening nonsense so what's
the deal well I have to reiterate that
not only is this the first incarnation
of the hero but no one ever even used
the power of the Triforce at this point
in history if link Spirit didn't have
the right balance of power wisdom and
courage the Triforce would have likely
split as soon as he tried using it like
it tends to do in that situation to make
matters worse there's a good chance that
the Triforce of power would have landed
on demise making him even more powerful
than he already was the goddess had to
make absolutely sure that link would be
able to control it hence why practically
all the preparations highly unmade are
catered towards link and not Zelda the
creation of the Goddess sword a Phi all
the trials the messages she left behind
the countless Hoops we had to jump
through it was all made specifically for
the hero to prepare him for the task
ahead I'd go as far as to say that the
reason why future incarnations of Link
were able to use the Triforce without
issue is exactly because they inherited
the same unbreakable Spirit forged by
the hero of the sky the event events in
Twilight Princess also showcased that
despite being in possession of it the
Triforce can lay dormant inside one's
body he clearly had the Triforce of
Courage from the very beginning most
likely from birth but it wasn't until he
selflessly crossed into the veil of
Twilight to save his friends that it
started showing the first signs of
Awakening as such it's more than
possible that the hero of the sky had
all three pieces hidden within but in
the same dormant State even so from the
very beginning link does show signs that
there's something different about him he
has premonitions of things he couldn't
possibly have any knowledge of like the
surface and demise he's unusually strong
and talented for someone of his stature
people even get onto him for the fact
that he never seems to put in any effort
yet still manages to come out on top he
also established an unusual spiritual
bond with his loftwing on a level never
before seen in skyloft going as far as
being able to sense that something's
wrong with his bird companion long
before it comes to light that gruce
imprisoned it all this stuff combined
the Silent Realm the Triforce Crest his
unusual Talent it should have been a
clear giveaway but perhaps because of
past knowledge of how the Triforce
normally works many of us simply brushed
off the possibility or flat out missed
it entirely so now let's go back to
where we started back to Zelda and her
ceiling power in breath of the Wild
foreign
about the hero of the sky is correct it
explains perfectly what we see happening
here it would explain a lot of things
actually such as why link didn't have
the Triforce of Courage despite so
obviously being the chosen hero of his
time why ganon's motivations have
seemingly shifted from dividing conquer
to outright genocide and destruction and
of course why Zelda suddenly went Super
Saiyan on us it's worth pointing out
that Zelda is a blood descendant of the
goddess and frequent holder of the
Triforce of wisdom has always possessed
great power seeing into the future
speaking telepathically summoning the
light arrows restraining Ganon so the
hero can deliver the decisive blow so on
and so forth but never before has she
been this powerful she succeeds in what
historically could only be achieved by
the combined strength of a whole group
of powerful individuals it's also the
first time in history that Zelda's
abilities have been referred to as a
ceiling power believe it or not that was
never established before breath of the
wild at most she would join the sages to
collectively seal the Demon King she
never did this alone she would have to
possess an immense amount of force in
order to pull something like this off
and the best explanation I can think of
is that she's tapping into the full
power of the Triforce here of course the
story of the hero of the sky if true
proves that carrying the Triforce within
for an extended period of time is
something that can be done but what it
doesn't prove is that it can also be
passed on by Blood firstly because we
don't know anything about Link's family
and Skyward Sword and secondly he still
ends up using it in the traditional way
by Wishing Upon the physical Triforce
and after that it's no longer in his
possession however I'm open to the
possibility if pieces can be inherited I
don't see why the whole thing would be
off limits it would be a first and quite
unusual but just because we haven't seen
it before doesn't mean it's impossible
perhaps at some point in the distant
Past after the events of all the other
games one of the ancestors of breath the
wild Zelda somehow found a new way to
use the Triforce and trained herself to
wield it in a way that has never been
done before instead of utilizing its
wish granting abilities she instead
tapped into the raw force that makes up
the Triforce as a source of power it
would explain why the physical Triforce
and the legend of the omnipotent power
that was once so prominent in Hyrule has
been lost since if it's been passed down
through Zelda's lineage for thousands of
years by this point knowledge about its
existence would have no doubt faded away
henceforth it became known under a new
pseudonym the ceiling power and nobody
alive today not even Zelda herself
realizes that the true origin of this
sacred gift lies in an ancient artifact
left behind by the gods many ages ago
that leaves us with one final piece of
conjecture If Zelda possesses the
complete Triforce how come she was
struggling so much to tap into it what
prevented her from using her power until
it was arguably too late and the kingdom
and most of her friends had already
fallen my guess is that similar to the
hero of the sky she had not yet unlocked
all three virtues necessary to control
it and with the premature death of her
mother there was no one to teach her how
the ceiling power Works praying at the
Springs was useless it was an old
tradition copied and derived from
Legends of old without actually
understanding its implications instead
the thing that held her back was simply
her own mental struggles it is my
suspicion that she had unlocked power
and wisdom as a scientist and Scholar
she was very wise for someone her age
and as we all know she's very powerful
much more powerful than she realizes I
think the virtue she was lacking was
courage throughout the memories we can
see that Zelda was oftentimes fearful
and not particularly Brave when push
came to shove she would freeze up and
others had to take action in her stead
the immense pressure placed on her
shoulders also meant she was in constant
doubt about herself and her
contributions which wasn't helped by the
fact that she received little to no love
or support from her Stern and impatient
father some like to think that it was
her love for the hero that finally
pushed her over the edge and awakened
her gift and a sweet and romantic as
that may be I don't fully agree with it
after all if you really think about it
it would suggest that her love for all
the other people she loved us at that
point apparently wasn't strong enough
the love for her own father for her best
friend herbosa were they not worthy of
being saved the fear of losing link was
no doubt a strong motivator but I don't
think it was the actual cause behind her
Awakening I think the reason her power
awakened when it did was because for the
first time she had the courage to step
in instead of standing back helplessly
once again and letting it all happen she
put herself In Harm's Way to save
someone she cared about and with this
act of Bravery she unlocked the final
virtue and with it her ultimate power
from this moment on we see a noticeable
shift in Zelda's Behavior she's no
longer the defenseless frustrated
insecure girl we saw in the other
memories she takes quick and decisive
action to save Link's life she takes it
upon herself to travel to the great
forest and return the master sword and
finally she makes the ultimate sacrifice
and faces Ganon alone if there's any
truth to all of this then it remains to
be seen if Zelda is still in possession
of the Triforce in the upcoming Sequel
and if the game will expand on the
history and origin of her ceiling power
she does make it clear in the final
cutscene that for whatever reason she
can no longer hear the voice inside the
master sword and that her powers have
dwindled over the last 100 years it's
possible that with that final surge of
energy she either exhausted the last of
its power and it needs to recharge or
perhaps she lost her connection to the
Triforce altogether who knows it is
obvious that previous incarnations of
Zelda use the ceiling power successfully
against Ganon and still manage to pass
it on to the next in line however they
didn't have to restrain The Demon King
for well over a century as far as we can
tell Zelda was forced to tap into her
power three times that is to say three
times total the Triforce Crest is seen
manifesting maybe she overextended as
powerful as the Triforce is it too seems
to have its limits
if you made it all the way to the end
thank you so much for watching a big
shout out to my fellow Zelda theorists
like zeltic quest with Aaron and rinkuto
who are willing to discuss and exchange
ideas also a big thanks to the one
Majora for allowing me to use some of
his free cam footage of the Silent Realm
you can find links to their channels in
the description below so be sure to
check them out last but not least a
shout out to my mods my Discord
community and of course to my supporters
on patreon and right here on YouTube a
very warm welcome to my newest
supporters which are Louis tavar dweller
meowamoto Toby Davies Turtle Alex and
Jairo or hero as always I cannot thank
you all enough for your generosity and
that is all for today stay awesome
everyone and I hope to see you all next
time
[Music]
thank you